jessica is in Arizona hi Jessica welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show I think you both
for having me on sure what's up
okay so my husband and I don't want to
act in here I mean we know that the
market is pretty much on sale right now
and we also don't want to be unwise
though and we're really just wondering
if and at what point we should cause
maybe that's four or five and six and
just stockpile cash during all this
chaos why my my drive is feeble I'm a
teacher so I'm not about that but my
husband does he's only practiced you the
chiropractor's you don't think based on
our state it will be shut down but
obviously like patient visits have
dropped dramatically pretty much in half
at this point and we just don't know how
long this will continue and you know if
he wants to make sure he's able to pay a
staff and continue to do those things so
we're just not really sure how to
analyze it does he have retained
earnings in his car practicals he does
um I think between like checking and
savings it's about a hundred thousand
dollars how much staff is he got he's
got another doctor in there and three
four employees okay
so what's it taking my month to pay them
fifteen thousand bucks
mm-hmm yeah I think like ten to fifteen
somewhere around there so I could make
it like ten months with no income yeah
he said you know especially on
bare-bones they could they could go a
long time yeah yeah I don't think why
would you need the pile of cash sound
like you got a pile of cash okay that's
kind of what we were debating yeah I
mean if there's a reason yeah if you
look look up and you go okay
if his revenue disappears for two months
you're fine right you can eat off a
girl's income at home and we'll use some
of that hundred to pay the bills down
there right yep and you could even ask
them to skip a little if you needed to
but I don't even think you'll need to
but if you told me you know you had
$10,000 down there yeah I'd probably
stop and pile up some cash to help his
practice survive because he may go you
know at two months with the equivalent
of two months of revenue oh it may be
over the next four but he's probably
going to lose some revenue
and so but you know what what I what
I've been telling our folks internally
here and and the entre leadership tribe
and Christie's been telling the business
boutique tribe people running businesses
is it is very difficult to slow down as
a leader and make calm decisions based
only on the facts and the facts are you
guys have a big pile of money and it
would have to go a long time before you
would need more unless I miss something
I don't think so I think it's just again
that you know he's worried about his you
know staff and just making sure that
they're taking care of I am too but I
think my point is the facts are that
they're taking care of okay you know
what's interesting Jessica the question
that you asked I'm asked all the time
from people it that they say it's
something like this Dave they say is
this fear or wisdom you know guiding my
decision is this fear or wisdom I can't
discern between the two and I always ask
them what are you afraid of and if
there's a practical factual answer well
I'm afraid of not being able to make
payroll because we have no retain during
earnings okay
okay there's there's a there's wisdom
there that's when wisdom is guiding your
decisions when I say what are you afraid
of and they say I don't know I'm just if
they don't have an answer that's when
it's this boogie monster it's this
elusive shadow that's just haunting you
that's like no he's afraid of not being
able to pay the staff right he's got the
money he's got the money that's what I
mean it's when it's unfounded when
there's no facts to back up the fear
when you look at this and go hey I
looked at the numbers and I am okay then
that's not something you need to be
afraid of that's wisdom that you've got
the cash piled up you're okay plenty of
other things to be worried about that
kelp cyou just start between the two if
you can answer the question and there's
a factual reason then yeah we need to
make some decisions with wisdom but if
it's just this this sense of fear
because of what's going on in the world
or you know we don't have an actual
numbers to you know you dial it by in
the case of Ramsey solutions okay we got
a thousand people here responsible for
paying the payroll right and so what are
we doing well when and if revenues
turned down and they likely will right I
in this environment then we have to
measure
against that right but until they do I'm
not gonna start measuring against it
because it might happen yeah I'm
watching it literally every day where I
used to look at it maybe once a month
and we're watching all the leading
indicators of the revenue the metrics
and the accounting pieces and all that
and a business's cisors all kinds of
things you can measure and look at and
and our guys are really good at helping
me do that and we got a great leadership
team to pull that off but what I keep
Targa's is we're gonna make decisions
based on not what we think could happen
but based on what is literally happening
right and and no it's not too late we're
gonna say when if something bad happens
then we'll do B if something good
happens then we'll do a and so we've got
a flow chart figured out the decisions
are already made if and when it turns up
or down right and if and when this
occurs or that occurs and you can put in
your flow chart decision-making but what
I'm trying to work with our leadership
team on and even in my own head space
between my own leaders is to say don't
oversteer don't overcorrect for
something that isn't there right yet be
prepared there might be a bridge out
ahead but we don't need to get off until
we get up there and just get off at the
exit until we get up there and there's
an actual detour sign because the bridge
is really out not we heard a rumor that
the bridge might be out right so we're
gonna cancel our trip you know and so
and that's what I keep trying to do and
every time I say that about the
coronavirus you know that then you just
get eviscerated you're not allowed to
say that about the mathematics of the
coronavirus because people just go
bananas and I'm Satan's child because I
bring that up but all that I'm trying to
do there is say let's deal with what is
really there and yeah you can look at
the scenarios of what might happen good
or bad you look at when the curve
flattens if there's a curve how it
flattens over what period of time it
flattens all that kind of thing and you
run those scenarios out but in case you
haven't noticed those are changing daily
too right and so and you not to be
Satan's child to question authority is a
good thing to question authority
before people get pissed off some of you
have lost your ever-loving minds it's a
hoot to watch how you miss brave but uh
cuz these reckless and irresponsible
when he's putting his employees lives in
jeopardy and yeah yeah I'm doing all
that I'm purposefully trying to kill my
employees how what a dumb butt thing to
say well what's interesting is this fear
and we've been talking about this but
even even in light of this question this
fear can be so consuming it actually
becomes your reality and steals your
present steals your joy steals your
peace and you're fine like you can feel
I've been at home just from you know
either listening to someone or hearing
someone and I noticed Dave my chest is
tight and my breath is short and I feel
myself getting it I'm like I'm fine
I'm at home I'm saying it's like we have
to watch what we put in our minds we
have to watch what we watch what we hear
we have to look at the actual facts your
situation for example your you've got
that pile of cash or your employees
which you're worried about Archive donor
by the way you've done it
you're set up for success and when you
look at those facts it allows you to
realize like like you said with the
bridge analogy hey if something happens
I'll deal with that I'm gonna be smart
and wise watching the dials watching the
revenue watching the the savings and so
on but today I am okay today I am safe I
am healthy I've got savings I am okay
and so I think that when we look at what
the moment that we're in being wise
about the future but not letting that
fear steal your joy from your present
that's really important at a time like
this
no it's Dave what if what if what if my
retirement is down because stock markets
down because guarana a virus when I get
ready to retire well so what oh I don't
know let's say you got $500,000 in your
retirement in your 401k and it goes down
to 400,000 okay which is probably about
what it's done roughly and and you
retired today right in the middle of
this well you weren't gonna cash it all
out anyway you're just gonna live off
the income so you got a little less
income but you didn't lose your
retirement and lose your income from it
and you don't want cash it out and now
anyway but you were gonna cash it all
out anyway you're gonna leave it in
there and let it pay you
and so you're not gonna move it anyway
so it doesn't change your retirement
plans but we get all caught up in the
drama of the stock market in the stock
markets a drama queen for sure